ragazzi una domanda chi vi chiedo così
siccome ho attivato i messaggi privati
su twitter e che ho scoperto adesso che
si poteva fare questa cosa però non so
come togliere il fatto che mi arrivò non
so commento
non so come non so come non so come
togliere fatti non so non so come
togliere il fatto che mi arrivano le
notifiche sul telefono qualcuno per caso
sa come si toglie questa cosa perché
sennò mi il telefono mi muore amica con
questo outfit sembrò un telecronista
sportivo per tutti i ragazzi è pervenuti
a questo video sono fa vigeva portiamo
prima con la fama della settimana anche
almeno una volta la facciamo perché la
vita mentre non la faccio ciò la noia
nell'anima e non c'ho voglia di metterlo
in editing questo disegno bello ve lo
faccio vedere sul telefono e va
attaccata al birillo eccolo qua ragazzi
la bagarre di oggi bellissima questa
fantasia verde che sembra non è finto
questa qui che bellissima avevo salvato
questa parte del telefono perché mi sono
detto tanto poi quando faccio blog la
metto perché è una figata pazzesca mi
metto anche a fuoco c'è scritto allora è
please vedilo cazzo io il cazzo lo vedo
perché mi faccio il video è spesso
congrega soli vi dico che cosa sta
succedendo perché una cosa molto ma
molto [ __ ] che credo piacerà un po tutti
youtube questo sito che forse voi
conoscerete mi ha contattato circa un
paio di mesi fa perché ha voluto che io
te stassi questa nuova funzionalità che
stanno mettendo su youtube che consiste
nel fare le live le live quindi in
diretta con il telefono sempre su
youtube che bisogna dire questa cosa
vuol dire che io con il mio telefono
questo qua che uso quando non c'ho
voglia di fare le cose tramite questo io
riuscirò a fare delle live qua su
youtube facendo vedere dove sono questa
è una funzionalità che youtube metterà
più avanti per tutti quanti ma prima di
lanciarla sul grande pubblico per
testare questa cosa a youtube ha preso
pochissimi youtuber in tutto il mondo
prendendoli come beta tester per questa
cosa faccio vuol dire che solo loro
questa funzionalità per adesso
indovinate un po che hanno scelto come
beta tester i sento tutto chirito this
world heart on line che adesso non solo
se non ho voglia di mettere le fan art
nei video faccio vedere col telefono
esso anche se non c'ho voglia di montare
i video li faccio col telefono e poi
[ __ ] ancora con per esso rispetto
ovviamente non farò mai
devi stare calmo non farò mai
ho detto che devi stare calmo non farò
mai del non farò mai
[Musica]
non farò non farò mai delle live come
unico video di giornata se farò delle
live le farò come secondo video di
giornata però potrà capitare che ogni
tanto io così impazzisca e vada in live
la cazzo di cane
ecco tutto quindi ragazzi che cosa ho
pensato di fare per questa occasione
bellissima siccome fare le live con
telefono è fighissimo però non ha senso
farlo in casa ho deciso di andare a
londra per una decina di giorni a
partire da pirata già da ieri solo che
questo video registrato prima però già
già mentre sta volando sto video io sono
a londra e durante questa permanenza a
londra io farò delle live direttamente
da londra ne farò 45 mentre sono lì se
volete essere notificati per quando mi
capiterà di andare in live c'è una cosa
che potete fare che quando siete
iscritti al mio canale perché voi siete
iscritti al mio canale qua sotto sotto
il video ci dovrebbe essere accanto al
tasto iscritto una campanella
non so perché casa c'è una campanella
però se voi la cliccate che capiti
scuola calcio di campanella schifosa
praticamente quando carico invito quando
vado in live velo notifica
la notifica quindi fatto suonare la
campanella che il mio canale diventa una
chiesa così i ragazzi questo è tutto ciò
che avevo da dirgli sull'argomento live
che sarà una bomba pazzesca spero quindi
voglio vedervi connessi tutti quando c
al ain 100.000 in live dobbiamo essere
tutti esplodere il mondo deve esplodere
quindi ragazzi passiamo oltre questa era
l'argomento live e vi racconto ragazzi
di una cosa che è successa questa
settimana molto molto bella ho girato
una sottospecie di doc documentario che
hanno fatto dove in mezzo ci sono
anch'io perché national geographic e mi
ha riconosciuto come animale selvatico e
quindi vuole studiare come vivono va beh
una roba del genere quindi è venuta
proprio della gente con delle
videocamere tutto il resto a riprendere
in casa mia io mentre registrava facevo
le cose li ho ripresi con la video con
la webcam devo farvi vedere le riprese
che ho fatto riforme fanno scassare
c'era tutta sta gente che compariva a
caso durante il video mentre io tentavo
di registrare rilascio degli spezzoni
perché farfa scassare ci avete pazienza
vela tutti ragazzi benvenute questo
nuovo video io sono fra i j
sarà di molto molto bella questa
settimana è come si sa non fate domande
per l'amor di dio però una cosa è
successa molto bella una cosa molto
bella vedete che ci sono queste chiazze
sul muro tipo hanno registrato con le
videocamere non è che hanno trasportato
le videocamere normalmente non l'hanno
trascinate sul muro che porca di una
[ __ ] rimasto il senso generico
mandati a casa mia mi sembra che
servizio le persone sul muro e le frusto
cerata no hanno strisciato le
videocamere per l'amor di dio vale prima
di concludere ragazzi visto che è una
cosa che continuano a chiedermi tutti e
non capisco il perchè però non mi va di
farci un video dedicato molti di voi da
quando c'è stato un natale mi stanno
chiedendo che cosa ho ricevuto io per
natale perché sono cresciuta non voglio
più giochi con gas
una volta mi divertivo con l'allegro
chirurgo adesso mi dò la scossa nei
video pensato che cazzo scommesso ma mi
hanno regalato due cose una volta i
ragazzi natale chiedevo le macchinine i
videogiochi la playstation
il calcetto entra adesso a natale ho
ricevuto questo che vi chiederete che
cazzo è e me lo sto chiedendo anch'io
ridata ai miei genitori mi hanno
regalato questa questa cosa che può
sembrare un po una tetta vi spiego cosa
dovrebbe fare questa cosa che vi faccio
vedere si mette un bicchiere d'acqua e
io so già che farò un casino che non
avete idea
ecco lo sapevo [ __ ] vacca importa
allora facciamo finta di niente perfetto
dopodichè ragazzi si prende questa cosa
che ci si traduca l'ipt o e se ci infili
due gocce dentro tipo poi ci infili
coperchio e spruzza il vapore
io che soffrono di congestione nasale la
cosa che faccio e questa è una figata
sta roba grazie mamma e papà che mi
avete preso questa cosa invece un altro
regalo che ho ricevuto ho ricevuto dalla
mia madrina che mi ha regalato una
macchinetta del caffè però io non bevo
il caffè
quindi ragazzi spero che questo video vi
sia piaciuto cosa semplice documento è
un mi piace conclude episodio ci vediamo
a londra in sintesi ricordatevi la
campanella che usano quando vado in live
bigon pol kat
rientra gatti spero che mi diceva certo
cosa semplice argomento è un mi piace
anche la pagina di facebook come di
descrizione si scateni ci vediamo al
prossimo video non posso chiudere col
telecomando quindi faccio entrare nella
nel vapore bella ragazzi
[Musica]